I was born and raised in Bloomfield New
Jersey as the son of a local elected
official and a homemaker and it's shaped
Who I am by being brought up in a family
that was very community-oriented very
public service oriented and that was my
world I was the councilman's kid growing
up through junior high in high school at
first I really didn't anticipate
entering politics I thought I would be
having a career in university
administration I aspired to be a Dean of
Students and then a university president
and I having been a one of the student
leadership geeks on campus at Arizona
State University I was student body
president there after I did that and
then stayed in Tempe Arizona where I
went to college people encouraged me to
get involved in the community and I
joined the local Kiwanis Club and got
involved with the Chamber of Commerce
and the tempe leadership program and the
next thing I knew people were saying you
should run for City Council and one
thing led to the next and I did and
spent 14 years in local office in
Arizona for as a councilmember antennas
the mayor well when I first ran I was
young I mean it was nineteen ninety i
was living in a fraternity house two
years before i was running for office
but my theme and the things i was
talking about was about bridging to the
future that was the theme i used before
Bill Clinton used it in 1996 by the way
I used it as my theme for running for
mayor of Tempe Arizona in 1994 and it
was all about knowing the community
having been there from college as solely
as a young adult and so forth and then
bridging to the future and looking to
the future and what do we want our
community to be and I was the youngest
person with the least amount of
experience running in that three-way
race for mayor that year but somehow got
elected and spent ten years in that
office
you